why I'm Kerry returning to the small
screen in the new dramedy kidding which
premieres Sunday and that Jim told et
that he'd be up for a reboot of his
breakout TV hit in living color the
sketch comedy series created by the way
nians what do you think about that
should that show make a return it's to
happen that show needs to exist again
universally now especially now man
there's so much to eat up and spit out
you know so I'd love to see it
reconstitute itself in another form you
know I go back and hang out with them
only if he comes back as fire marshal
bill yeah that's always one of his big
characters that Dana says yes how
exciting I'm shocked that Jim Carrey
would be up for this though cuz I cuz
he's irrelevant right now no cuz he's
changed so much like he's not the same
guy that did Ace Ventura so I'm just
shocked that you'd be up to return to
the show that like wheezes yeah Kim or
Naren but do you not want to go back to
the era where you were loved do you want
to go back Jim do you want to be a part
of something when everyone loved you and
you're at the height of your career he's
like yeah let me keep you try to bring
my basement sure so I'm like that I'm
just shocked that you wouldn't let me
show you something yeah there is right
there that's incredible stuff that's a
big Fox they think we're not good like
the Wayans brothers back agenda box it
could be cool and then but some people
at home right now are like what do you
guys talking about there's an age
demographic who is like but look it up
watch the skits on YouTube they're
absolutely incredible how's this this is
very mannered and polished now yeah I
don't know Jim Carrey is still the same
goofy guy the fire marshal feel like I
feel like just a little bit like a dude
like Rebecca said she never watched it
but she thinks it should come back
Rebecca check it out hilarious no here's
yeah yonce the Jen says In Living Color
produced so many great communities of
dancers JLo was one of them yeah so it's
a like now JLo could do the dance number
go-go girl well this woman climbers
again the fire so she was like in the
back
that show comes back yeah she'd be like
the lead dancer just do the dance I
think they didn't like in the commercial
breaks of her coming out of the
commercial break so yeah
there's potential the Wayans brothers
where's Kenan where's Kenan these days
hobby bridge just relaxing on a pile of
money Monica says have an amazing show I
hope they bring her back we'll see now
that Jim said yes I feel like he's my
back yeah quite snowball or something